we've suspected it for quite some time
but now
it's official england has the highest
level of excess mortality
in europe and let me show you what that
means excess mortality of course
it's a measure of just how many people
are dying above the seasonal
average and so these lines basically
show you that the higher they are
the more people dying than would
normally do around that time of year and
you can see the pandemic
rising across europe each of these lines
different european countries but you can
see the uk
highlighted there let me show you in
relation to spain which is the other
country which peaked
uh at a high level and the uk now higher
than spain and in particular england
we'll just take that latest point
there so this is mid-2020 and you can
see again the
higher these bars are the higher levels
of excess mortality are the more
the impact of covered 19 you can see
some nordic countries so norway
denmark finland down there lower people
lower levels of excess mortality fewer
people dying than usual
but look at the top england at the very
top then
the uk uh as a whole then spain then
scotland
interestingly so scotland above italy
above belgium
when it comes to excess mortality then
wales and then sweden
and the netherlands and other than
northern ireland really it's striking
just how
high up all the different constituent
parts of the uk are on this and if you
look at a map
of the intensity of mortality during
this period this shows you in april 2020
so kind of the peak
of the pandemic just look the darker the
areas that you can see here the more
blue they are
the higher levels of excess mortality
are across regions
of the uk but now compare that with
other parts of europe so for instance
look at spain now there is an intense
pocket around
madrid but different parts of spain not
quite so affected so towards the south
uh not quite so much mortality and the
same thing again
when you look at france and italy so
northern italy bergamo milan
at high levels of mortality very high
higher actually than many parts of the
uk
similar thing in paris but look at
different parts of france
and parts of italy far lower levels of
mortality underlines the fact
that for much of europe this was a
regional crisis regional pockets
of the disease whereas for the uk it was
a national crisis